new developments in the justice Millette
case the producers of empire say they're
removing his character from the final
two episodes of the current season the
actor met with the cast and crew
yesterday he reportedly apologized and
maintains his innocence
some less lawyers also firing back at
Chicago authorities saying quote mr.
Smollett is a young man of impeccable
character and integrity and fiercely and
solemnly maintains his innocence
betrayed by a system that apparently
wants to skip due process and proceed
directly to sentencing meantime Chicago
leaders continue to criticize smollett
Mayor Rahm Emanuel saying he put the
city at risk you have put all those real
stories at risk for your fake story that
is not right that it's not right for
Chicago that is not right for what kind
of city we are that is the city I know
that is the recipient of the city they
care in our common humanity and he put
that all at risk you want to get it paid
more get an agent but don't use your
sexual orientation
don't use your race and have everybody
sympathies come to you and it turns out
it was none of that was true Wow mayor
Emanuel getting after him Greg yeah
that's I haven't seen him that mad since
chick-fil-a lawyers blaming the system I
I wrote that down it's the system and
again they're using the terms that they
hope and grace she ate with with the
media it's like because I mean to blame
the system I am oppressed this guy
wasn't oppressed he was making 60 to 100
thousand dollars an episode and still
only paid the two Nigerians $3500 so
he's worse than a liar he's a cheap
bastard seriously I am you know I'm a
theory on why a lot of people fell for
this I don't think anybody here what
thought this was real but I think a lot
of students who went to college in the
last decade ears are or so are now
employed in media entertainment human
resources and they went to college when
the victimhood virus began right and so
they've graduated and they've moved on
and they're in newspapers they're on TV
they're working in television they fall
for this they but they don't have the
immune system to see that these story
I'm trying to be I'm trying to be
forgiving here but they don't have the
immune system
see what a bunch of baloney this is but
if you've been around if you've been
around for in the real world you would
have smelled this and and you wouldn't
have given it all the attention
unfortunately CNN they have a lot of
people that fell for it I have this guy
in the two o'clock showed the daily
briefing today Jesse his name is Erik
desin Hall and he's involved in crisis
management and has done a lot of big
cases celebrity cases and things like
that and he said that it is often the
case that somebody who is a perpetrator
of such a thing doesn't even realize
like truly does not realize how much
trouble they are in and do we have this
auto it's not let's play that in almost
every case I've ever seen they genuinely
believe themselves to be victims even
even if they did the thing they're
accused of the rationale is I had a
reason that people like you just don't
understand and they're right like I
don't understand
but should I yeah well he's facing hard
time especially if the feds catch him on
that terrorism beef I like the old Greg
Gutfeld which is I like the unforgiving
tough-as-nails Greg yeah I don't like
this new forgiving how he's dead it's
resolution I'm going to forgive those
who are truly victim okay well I will
not forgive anybody okay I hate these
people
legal team because I think they're being
totally asinine they have now victimized
the Chicago Police Department and the
city twice smollett sandbag the police
department send them on all these
wild-goose chases after they gave them
the benefit of the doubt made them waste
all this time and money and now the
legal team is coming out and saying
they're corrupt this is a political
prosecution and there's an injustice
taking place that is the dumbest
possible strategy I could ever imagine
them taking if I were them I would say
and it's it until proven guilty my
client will wait to all the facts came
out maybe there's some more things that
no one knows about and then I would
hunker down and go dark what they're
doing dynamic is is a betrayal of what
they should be doing as attorneys
because they're landing him in more
trouble because now the police hate him
even more because they're trying to make
them a double victim right
because he was he was the fake victim of
the perpetrated pokes and now he's the
victim of a system that apparently is
trying to sentence him before he has his
day in court
yeah I mean I think it's the same thing
but yeah he I mean he's there they're
making him out to be the victim so what
fascinated me was reading that yesterday
he went to the set of the show and he
goes to the set of the show and
apparently is crying heavily he makes
the crew wait 30 minutes and then Jesse
what's the show where's one so he goes
and he's crying
you haven't seen you cry not only cries
but then he says to the crew to the
people he works with daily that he's not
guilty
yep and he promises them that this is
true he is a man of dignity and faith
and integrity I don't know what's going
on you know let's take a listen to
Charles Barkley he had comments on this
and we get Emily's thoughts America and
we just tell you something is that do
not commit crimes with check you cannot
if you're gonna break the law
now obviously the Chicago Police
Department goes not laughing but those
little moment of levity yeah I thought
that was funny and I liked the humor
that I brought to it I will say I
obviously agree with you
as an attorney I agree with you that the
strategy deployed right now by his legal
team it's surprising and they are
calling attention to the wrong aspect to
the wrong angle and you are right that
they should have been behind the scenes
doing all that they can to mitigate what
is frankly a personal offense being
taken by the city of Chicago right we've
seen the mayor we saw the superintendent
the that city is not forgiving anyone
anytime soon and interestingly you know
I see this kind of digging in and
refusing to admit anything oftentimes
when the weight of the government comes
and unit turns its eye to you but here
it could literally be some type of case
of narcissism where as you were saying
earlier when you honestly believe that
you are in the right and that no matter
what even if you acknowledge the
physical execution of something that
you're not actually guilty that's what
Bill Koch is doing from prison right now
see misremembering
didn't we have recovered memories
there's only I you know I don't know I
think that he he can't afford to confess
yet oh I think what he's going to do
though is he's good I think he's going
to talk about a drug problem because
that's what I would do hey you know what
I think that that won't get him off
great yeah because what we saw for mom
Rahm Emanuel what was really great was
emotion and Rahm Emanuel said his mother
came to when she was in Chicago was
working for racial justice and he says
what smollett did and I think Berkeley
picked up on this he's making it harder
now for people because racists will say
that anybody who says that they are a
victim is a liar people bigots will say
that it's okay in terms of hopefully
that is not true and I'll say that the
worst way to look at it actually took
him seriously for three weeks that's why
they're mad yeah all right